I'm gonna get so many followers never
never doing that again I'm never doing
that again
[Music]
hi everyone it's Charlie this is gonna
be my spider-man far from home post
credit scene and video for the ending
there's so many big things that they set
up there are two post-credit scenes
hopefully you've had a chance to see the
movie if you're brand new to the channel
we're still doing that IMAX ticket
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a spider-man
comment on the video if for some reason
you have not seen the movie yet careful
for spoilers there will be a rampant
spoilers because we'll be talking about
the end of the movie in all the post
credits so starting at the end of the
movie spider-man manages to get back his
spidey sense which Aunt May
affectionately names the Peter tingle
earlier in the movie it turns into a big
joke so using his spidey sense he's able
to defeat Mysterio's very real illusions
that they're creating with a combination
of
Iron Man's BA our effing technology
which we learned earlier Mysterio
himself created when he was still
working for Tony Stark he's a former
stark Tech employee that got fired he
combined that technology with weaponized
drones created by the scientist from
Iron Man 1 in a big call back he was the
person that got yelled at by Obadiah
Stane for being incompetent so quick
Mysterio explainer just like in the
comics he was lying about everything and
he's the master of illusion but the way
they create the illusions is just a
little bit different when Quentin Beck
was still working for Tony Stark
his life's work was what became the be
ar effing technology tony fired him
after he lost his [ __ ] during a Captain
America Civil War flashback to the scene
where he's talking to his parents as a
child using the technology so Mysterio
feels like he trashed his life work and
that's what his big Vendetta is my
life's work and he names it barf he
gathers a team of other people from
Stark Industries that were either fired
or people that hated Tony Stark and they
create what becomes Mysterio's big plan
during the movie the whole MacGuffin of
the movie was the Edith glasses which
are sort of a backdoor to all of Iron
Man's weaponry and technology all over
the world so when Spiderman is about to
take the glasses back Mysterio says that
he has contingency plans because he
senses that Peter is going to defeat him
Peter seemingly watches him die with his
own eyes thinking that it's real because
his spidey sense doesn't go off
in the Edith AI system tells them that
there are no active illusions but
Mysterio does two things as part of his
contingency plans he one records and
edits special footage of their fight to
make it look like Spiderman was the
villain the whole time into secretly I
think the idea is that Mysterio used
practical effects not illusions to fake
his death sleight of hand to trick
spider-man's spidey sense and so that no
illusions would be detected but the
movie doesn't answer that question so if
Quentin Beck is still alive out there we
won't find out - a future movie but I
think the idea is that he is and he
would return for sinister six action in
a later film but then spider-man and MJ
go back to New York City with everyone
he confronts Aunt May and happy about
their relationship there kind of a thing
during the movie they played for comedy
like they just say well we're friends
with benefits we'll see where it goes
he takes MJ web-slinging through New
York City they have a funny scene of her
just freaking out oh we're never gonna
do that again totally crazy but then as
he's getting ready to leave a news
broadcast starts about their final fight
in they air the fake footage making
spider-man look like a villain this is
the first mid-credits scene it's very
important not quite as big as the second
post-credit scene for Marvel phase 4
stuff but this definitely teases
something that's gonna be happening
during Marvel phase 4
during the footage Mysterio looks into
camera and obviously he's faking
everything saying spider-man attacked me
for no reason he says that he's the only
one who's going to succeed Iron Man
although this belongs to him it makes it
look like spider-man orders this giant
drone attack if you're a big fan of
Tobey Maguire era you're gonna love this
next part too
because then it was revealed that Jay
jonah Jameson of The Daily Bugle dotnet
is the person who screamed the video and
gave it to the news service in its JK
Simmons back doing Jay jonah Jameson in
the MCU
they change it a little bit so it's more
of an Alex Jones conspiracy person's
spin on what he's doing with the Daily
Bugle that just feels like it's updated
for a more contemporary environment so
he's doing more video hit pieces on
spider-man instead of traditional
newspapers because not that many people
read traditional newspapers anymore so
he just looks a little bit different but
it's the same basic idea he's gonna
start running a bunch of hit pieces on
spider-man spider-man is terrible
everyone should hate him JJ says that
Mysterio is probably the greatest hero
that the world has ever seen he tries to
make him sound like he was even better
than Ironman at the end of Avengers end
game then here's the second part -
Mysterio's video where Mysterio outs
Peter Parker's secret identity as
spider-man putting his picture up for
the world to see so the entire world
knows now that Peter Parker is
spider-man spider-man slaps his face and
has the same WTF reaction that Aunt May
had it's the exact same line that she
added the end of spider-man homecoming
when she walked in on him getting into
costume and found out that he was
spider-man WTF I assumed that JK Simmons
J jonah Jameson will be a bigger
character during spider-man 3 they
haven't announced what the story for
that is but this mid-credits scene is
basically a teaser for the biggest
problem that he's going to be facing
going into that next spider-man film is
is it how is he gonna deal with this now
that all of his villains are gonna call
open season on Peter Parker spider-man
they all know who he is so they can find
out where he lives where his friends
live they can come after Aunt May now
which is exactly what happened in the
comics during Marvel Civil War when he
publicly outed himself as spider-man
it's right out of the comics what ended
up happening after that too is that they
had to do the one more day storyline the
only way for Peter to save Aunt May from
dying because someone had finally gotten
to her was to go to Mephisto broker a
deal which wound up erasing his
relationship with Mary Jane now
obviously they're not gonna do one more
day in the movies it'll be a little bit
different but remember the spider-man
homecoming post-credit scene with
scorpion and vulture scorpion wanted
vulture to tell him spider-man's secret
identity now he doesn't need to he can
see it on the news so this just paves
the way for a sinister six movie later
on whether that's going to be spider-man
3 or it's gonna be some other movie
after that we don't
how long it's gonna take to get to
sinister six but this is setting the
stage for a more Dark Reign type of
territory because yes Nick Fury has
stuff going on in the other post credits
scene that I'll talk about in a second
but the world still needs another Iron
Man figure that role is still empty
because Mysterio just poisoned the world
against spider-man the second
post-credit scene I think is even bigger
for the future of Marvel phase 4 they
played it for comedies so I think that a
lot of people didn't pay too much
attention to what was happening
especially at the very end of it but
they revealed that Nick Fury and Maria
Hill had been Scrolls this whole time
the entire movie every time you saw them
they were Scrolls masquerading as those
- it was Talos in his wife from the
Captain Marvel movie that had come back
they even for shattered it at the
beginning of the movie in the opening
scene in a couple times there after the
first time they have dialogue Maria hill
calls Nick Fury Nick everybody calls me
fury not Nicholas not Joseph not Nick
just fury fury kids
nobody caused him Nick everyone calls me
fury that should be the first giveaway
that they're not the real Maria hill and
Nick Fury then later when Mysterio is
explaining the multiverse to spider-man
for the first time Nick Fury says he's
from Earth just not yours instead of
saying are earth so as they're driving
away Talos talks to his wife about how
upset he is that Mysterio was able to
fool him with all these illusions a
shapeshifter it's embarrassing they call
Nick Fury and tell him that he has to
come back because things just went
completely off the rails and you learned
the only reason that they were supposed
to be pretending to be Nick Fury Maria
hill was is because he asked them to
execute the final part of Tony Stark's
will give the Iron Man glasses to
spider-man that's all they were supposed
to do they weren't supposed to get
involved with any of this Mysterio stuff
so Talos is admitting to completely
messing up the situation with Nick Fury
being off on vacation they revealed that
he's on a beach but the beach is
actually an illusion itself just another
wink at the whole Mysterio plot with the
illusions and he's been taking a short
vacation break on a giant space station
in orbit that looks like the sword
station from the comics as if they're
teasing
toward for Marvel phase four another
indicator that this is actually the
sword Space Station of the comics he
yells everyone as if he's in charge
tells them to get back to work and who's
seen my shoes because he's walking
around without shoes on the reason why
that's a big deal is is because sword
teases very big cosmic threats that Nick
Fury is preparing for shield was
designed to deal with earth-based
threats emanating from earth sword is
all about dealing with bigger cosmic
threats the annihilators the Celestials
characters like Galactus any big
space-based fleet or threat you want to
think of so that feels very much like a
Marvel phase four wink and it's a big
reference to his very first post-credit
scene at the end of the first Iron Man
felt teasing The Avengers initiative
you're part of a bigger world stark and
he's getting ready to tell him about the
Avengers so it's sort of a bookend to
his original post credits scene but also
setting up the next big team that he'll
put together the next Avengers team
there's been rumors about them doing an
ultimate steam that would be something
that they would do on that space station
they even have a couple cosmic teasers
during the movie there's a teaser for
Nova when they're doing all the movies
on the airplane the joke is is that the
world has developed movies and
television shows and documentaries to
talk about the things that have happened
the last couple of years so there's a
movie about the snap there's a movie
called finding Wakanda there's a movie
called hunting Hydra there's a nova
documentary with Erik Selvig teasing the
Nova character obviously and then
there's an Iron Man one called heart of
iron so even though it's meant to be a
very funny scene Talos saying I'm sorry
Nick Fury I kind of screwed up even
though I gave the glasses to the kids
things got kind of dicey it's actually
doing way way bigger things for the
future of the MCU I know you have a
thousand other questions about Norman
Osborn's sinister six Green Goblin all
the other big spider-man villains that
they might do with in the spider-man
films and then all the other big Marvel
phase four stuff that they teased during
the movie so be a bunch more Easter egg
videos this week if there's any really
big questions that you want me to make
videos for just let me know in the
comments but congratulations to AB
gamers you're the giveaway winner for my
last big Marvel video please email me on
the about page of my channel so I can
get your details click here for that
brand new Avengers and game post-credit
scene from the re-release and click here
for that brand
Shazaam black adam deleted scene thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]